alexis bonsoir merci de nous avoir
rejoints pour décrypter les dernières
mesures on le disait une troisième doses
pour les personnes vulnérables dès la mi
septembre ou encore la fin des tests
gratuits toutes ces annonces est ce qu
on pouvait s'y attendre finalement
oui puisque on voit bien que le
gouvernement suit un plan une feuille de
route qui est celle de dire que dans
quelques mois il n'y aura plus
d'épidémie et comment faire pour qu'il
n'y ait plus d'épidémie et bien tout
simplement arrêter de tester les gens et
les vacciner une fois que vous êtes
vacciné vous avez un saint graal qui
vous permet d'aller dans des bars dans
des restaurants dans des tgv à droite à
gauche sans masque et vous n'êtes plus
contaminant c'est faux j'aimerais
rappeler à gabriella talent que vacciner
vous pouvez est contaminée et finir à
l'hôpital exactement comme avec les
tests qui vous n'empêche qu'ils
n'empêchent pas de contaminer et de
finir à l'hôpital donc la stratégie du
tout vaccinal choisi par mails matheron
qui a aujourd'hui annoncé que dès la
rentrée les écoles seront des centres de
vaccination géant est une stratégie qui
va aller droit à l'échec ou qui va
permettre en fait de jouer sur les
chiffres ce que feu le mieux et le maine
macro chiffres du chômage chiffre de la
relance chiffres du copil plus de tests
plus d'épidémie c'est formidable alors
tout vacciner évidemment on aura tous le
coc vite peut-être alors peut-être pas
des formes graves parce que c'est là où
la vaccination fonctionne au moins c'est
d'éviter d'aller à l'hospitalisation
chez les personnes au moins qui ne sont
pas et menu des prix mais pour les
autres c'est la troisième dose pour les
autres c'est le risque aussi d'avoir des
variants qui vont être plus dangereux
pour les personnes vaccinées je voudrais
rappeler les paroles d'andrew polar qui
est l'équivalente d'alain fischer en
grande bretagne la grande bretagne qui
est un pays massivement vacciner avec
astrazeneca au début et puis qui a pris
là également le vaccin de pfizer et qui
dit qu'aujourd'hui l'immunité de groupe
les musiques collective ne sera pas
atteinte avec la vaccination elle sera
atteinte tout simplement parce que tout
le monde aura eu le coc vide à un moment
ou un autre et l'idée aujourd'hui c'est
d'éviter qu'on meurt du coc vide ou
qu'on fasse une forme grave qui amène à
l'hospitalisation que emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui disent que les enfants vont
être vaccinés à la rentrée parce que
c'est la seule solution je pense que
c'est une erreur je pense que c'est à
laval je suis pas épidémiologistes mais
j'écoute les économistes ailleurs les
pays qui ont massivement vacciner le
retour d'expérience de ces pays là
qu'ils disent qu'aujourd'hui oui certes
il faut vacciner mais il faut vacciner
les personnes qui sont surtout il menu
des prix mais surtout à risque de faire
un coup vite dangereux alors choisir
cette stratégie c'est une question qui
se pose pourquoi vouloir aller là où
certains français ne veulent pas aller
il n'y a pas de mouvement
antivaccin il y en a mais ils sont
minoritaires mais il y a des gens qui se
posent des questions sur l'avenir de
leurs enfants est ce que aujourd'hui une
piqûre à 12 ans veut dire une piqûre
chaque année puisqu'on voit trois
piqûres est ce qu'aujourd'hui si vous
êtes vacciné contre le coc ville à 12
ans ça veut dire que chaque année vous
devrez être vaccinés contre le coc vide
est ce que on ne sait rien de cette
épidémie et on a l'impression que les
modèles macron veut faire croire qu'il
connaît qu'il sait ce qu'il faut faire
et que la seule façon de relancer
l'économie et de relancer le pays c'est
cette vaccination massive alors certes
elle va permettre comme je le disais
d'éviter les formes graves et on espère
que ça va fonctionner mais qui conte
sera t'il des prochains variant personne
ne peut le dire aucun épidémiologiste au
monde et je parle là encore sous le
contrôle d des médecins et des
scientifiques donc on a là un choix
idéologique qui est celui de faire
croire à la population française de
grâce au vaccin tout va redevenir comme
avant avec le pass sanitaire qui va
faire une discrimination de fait entre
ceux qui ont le pass ceux qui n'ont pas
le pass et que faire est évidemment un
de ceux qui ne peuvent pas avoir accès à
ce pas ce soit pour raison médicale soit
pour raison personnelle enfin peu
importe on est en train de rentrer quand
même dans un monde assez dangereux assez
délicat et assez volatil puisqu'on ne
sait pas finalement de quoi il va
advenir dans les mois qui viennent en
tout cas pour prouver l'efficacité de la
vaccination a le chef de l'état s'est
appuyé sur la situation aux antilles qui
offre je cite la démonstration cruel que
la vaccination est le moyen le plus
efficace face au virus est ce que
finalement c'est pas aussi une façon de
dire aux antillais vous êtes des mauvais
élèves
emmanuel macron ne sais faire que ça
critiquer et dire aux français qu'ils
sont stupides qu'ils sont idiots qu'il
n'aurait compris et qu'ils sont
effectivement des mauvais élèves parce
qu'ils n'obéissent pas emmanuel macron à
un moment je crois que ça commence à se
voir d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il ya
autant de gens dans les rues qui a telle
vague finalement de fronde face à ce
pouvoir exécutif qui voudrait que tout
le monde obéit gouverner ce n'est pas
demander aux gens de venir gouverner
c'est prévoir emmanuel macron n'a rien
prévu sur les masques il n'a rien prévu
sur les tests s'ils n'avaient rien prévu
sur les vaccins il avait appris du
rappelez-vous le début de la campagne
vaccinale qui était un fiasco total il
se rattrape aujourd'hui et je voudrais
que ce soit la faute des français il à
moi à nous pardon à une semaine du
confinement généralisée il disait avec
brigitte macron aux français d'aller au
théâtre parce que c'est formidable
théâtre et puis après ça il a fermé les
théâtres et tous les lieux de culture
parce que c'était des commerçants
l'essentiel qui peut aujourd'hui encore
croire ces menteurs qui n'ont fait que
mentir changé d'avis et ajuster
finalement la parole semaine après
semaine pour dire aux gens d'obéir parce
qu'ils avaient raison ils n'ont fait
qu'avoir tort et aujourd'hui la raison
la raison c'est justement d'attendre de
voir ce qui va se passer et de dire
attendez je ne fais pas forcément
confiance emmanuel macron parce que il
s'est un peu trompé ces derniers mois
les gens ont tendance à oublier ce
conseil de défense sanitaire il est
antidémocratique par essence un
président de la république en 5ème
république certes il est garant des
institutions il a à peu près tous les
droits mais fair en plus un conseil de
défense pour éviter tout débat
parlementaire sur chaque décision
sanitaire c'est vraiment aller encore
plus loin de ce qui est permis par la
loi grâce aux mesures d'exception grâce
à la crise sanitaire qui vont durer
jusqu'en novembre décembre donc
aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans un état
d'exception qui permet à emmanuel macron
de faire n'importe quoi ce qu'il veut
finalement des français et les français
n'y trouve rien à redire puisque
certains sont très heureux de montrer
leurs passes sanitaires à la terrasse
des restaurants d'accepter que la police
vienne leur demander leurs papiers
d'identité alors qu'ils prennent un café
en terrasse c'est du délire et personne
n'a
le bon sens la raison de dire mais
qu'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
finalement est-ce qu'on lutte contre un
virus ou est-ce qu'on lutte contre un
peuple est ce qu'on lutte contre eux
efficacement sanitairement contre un
virus ou est ce qu'on est en train de
mettre en place un système de contrôle
permanent de contrôle social dont on ne
veut pas dans ce pays et aujourd'hui on
voit bien que les manifestants eh bien
ils sont montrés du doigt comme les
mauvais élèves comme ceux qui ne font
pas pour n'importe quoi les dangereux
ceux qui vont disséminer le virus encore
plus que les autres ceux qui n'obéissent
pas eh bien je ne crois pas je crois que
le principe d'une démocratie c'est
justement d'accepter ce qu'ils
n'obéissent pas de faire qu'il y ait un
débat avec ceux qui obéissent ce qui ne
laisse pas ceux qui trouvent que c'est
bien ceux qui trouvent que ce n'est pas
bien c'est cette force là la force du
débat qui fait la grandeur d'une
démocratie aujourd'hui le débat est
empêchée en france et c'est extrêmement
inquiétant merci beaucoup alexis poulain
d'avoir partager votre point de vue ce
soir sur rtl france